es kann offensichtlich nicht schnell
genug gehen russlands Präsident Putin
will jetzt also so schnell wie möglich
die Annexion von vier ukrainischen
Gebieten offiziell machen eine große
Zeremonie soll es dazu geben im Kreml
sollen die Beitrittsverträge
unterzeichnet werden die
separatistenführer sind bereits gestern
in Moskau angekommen nach den
Unterschriften folgt dann wohl auch
Putins große Rede umfassen soll sie
nämlich sein kündigt kremitschef pescof
an und seit Tagen wird spekuliert was
Putin neben der erwarteten Propaganda
wohl verkünden wird wird erweitert dem
besten Drohnen von taktischen Atombomben
sprechen das alles zur Stunde noch
unklar der ukrainische Präsident wurde
mir selenski forderte die Menschen in
Russland dazu auf Putin zu stoppen sie
müssen den einen in Russland stoppen der
Krieg mehr will als ihr Leben das Leben
der Menschen in Russland International
wurde die angekündigte alexion schon im
Vorfeld verurteilt und das jetzt hier
also die Livebilder aus dem Kreml in
Moskau Wladimir Putin will hier mit
seiner Unterschrift das referend
offiziell machen und bei mir im Studio
dazu Militärexperte Björn Strietzel
grüße Dich also jetzt dann also die
große Feier im Kreml was erwartest du
was erwartest du vor allem auch von der
Rede von Wladimir Putin
also nach nach der letzten nach der
letzten öffentlichen Rede in der sich
mit dieser Mobilmachung noch einmal noch
einmal deutlich gemacht hat in welcher
schwierigen Lage sich die russischen
Streitkräfte in der Ukraine befinden
erwarte ich jetzt eigentlich eine eine
Rede die tatsächlich ähnlich defensiv
wird weil nämlich weil nämlich diese
Territorien die dort anerkannt werden
sind zu einem großen Teil zumindest was
die Bevölkerungszahlen angeht nicht mal
mehr unter Kontrolle der russischen
Streitkräfte das heißt dort werden dort
werden Territorien annektiert ohne dass
man überhaupt die Mehrzahl der
Bevölkerung teilweise auch die große des
Territoriums unter Kontrolle hat der
krimisprecher pestov hat ja noch mal
darauf hingewiesen dass die Teile der
Regionen also in sapoji beispielsweise
ist die Hauptstadt ja weil noch nie
unter Kontrolle der russischen
Streitkräfte sind befindet sich
weiterhin ja in der Souveränität des
ukrainischen Staates dass diese dann
trotzdem dass diese Annexion trotzdem
die Jura auch gilt für die gesamten für
den gesamten Bereich
das wiederum hat natürlich nach der
russischen Militär Doktrin was Angriffe
auf das Staatsgebiet der russischen
Föderationen angeht wiederum folgen die
tatsächlich dann auch die Drohungen mit
nuklearen mit taktischen Nuklearwaffen
beinhalten könnten denn jeder Angriff
also jeder Offensive der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte zu Befreiung ihres Landes
die er zur Stunde weitergeht die könnte
dann als Legitimation herangezogen
werden von den russischen Streitkräften
bzw der politischen Führung also sprich
im Endeffekt Wladimir Putin für den
Einsatz taktischer taktische
Nuklearwaffen du hast eben schon diese
taktischen Atomwaffen angesprochen worin
liegt hier der Unterschied zu Atomwaffen
also sind ebenfalls Atomwaffen der
Unterschied besteht sozusagen in der im
Wesentlichen wenn man es herunterbrechen
will in der Auswahl der Ziele in der in
der in der weniger in der in technischen
Daten als in der Auswahl der Ziele
prinzipiell lässt sich zwar sagen dass
taktische Nuklearwaffen weil sie eben
für den Einsatz im Gefecht also für die
für den unmittelbaren Einsatz gegen
gegen feindliche gegen feindliches
Militär geeignet sind etwas geringere
Wirkungskraft etwas geringere
Zerstörungskraft damals strategische
Atombomben allerdings gibt es auch
Atomsprengköpfe die beide Rollen
erfüllen also strategischen Atomwaffen
würde man würde man zum Beispiel ja
große zivile Infrastruktur Städte des
Gegners Gegners zerstören diese
taktische Atomwaffen haben dann eben den
haben eben diesem diese besondere
Eigenschaft oder nicht diese besondere
Eigenschaft sondern zeichnen sich
dadurch aus dass sie bei sie im Gefecht
eingesetzt werden können die die
Hemmschwelle sie einzusetzen etwas
geringer ist als mit strategischen
Atomwaffen sozusagen eine
Millionenmetropole des Gegners
auszulöschen und insofern ist das
zumindest ja alles Theorie weil
taktische Atomwaffen noch nie im noch
nie in einem Krieg eingesetzt wurden ist
immer diese Theorie dass das sozusagen
ein gegenseitiges hochschaukeln sein
könnte das heißt der Hochphase des
Kalten Krieges war das Großteil des
Arsenals bei der Atom Supermächte waren
taktische Atomwaffen und man hat es dann
sukzessive reduziert um die um ein
solches hochschaukeln bis hin zu
strategischen Atomwaffen dann zu
unterbinden also wir sehen hier noch mal
die Live-Bilder kurz vor der
annexionszeremonie im Kreml wir erwarten
dass Putin die Annexion der besetzten
Gebiete verkündet welches Signal gibt er
damit an die Welt
also das hat er natürlich vor allem
seine seine Ansprüche sozusagen auf die
auf die
auf die Zerstückelung des souveränen
ukrainischen Staates noch einmal
bekräftigt wobei natürlich dieses
wenn wir das Vergleichen mit dem mit dem
mit der Ausgangsposition mit dem die
russische russischen Streitkräfte diese
Invasion gestartet haben am 24 Februar
als noch um die Zerschlagung der
gesamten Ukraine geht um die Absetzung
des wie ist die russische Propaganda
nannte Nazi Regimes in Kiew davon hat
man sich aufgrund der militärischen
Niederlagen verabschiedet und versucht
jetzt eben nur noch die Gebiete die man
halt gerade noch so hält einzugliedern
mit mit diesen scheinreferenten und das
Signal ist natürlich auch in dem Fall
eher ja keinen kein Signal der Stärke
was davon ausgeht sondern das ist eher
ein eher ein Signal der Schwäche wenn
man jetzt auch noch die
teilmobilisierung verkünden musste dann
diese diese
Territorien eingliedern muss obwohl man
eben nicht mal den Großteil der
Bevölkerung dort sozusagen in diesem
Gebieten hat jemand besetzt hat
teilweise nicht mal die Hauptstädter der
der jeweiligen Region
du hast es angesprochen Putin droht mit
taktischen Atomwaffen was glaubst du was
hörst du blöd er
sozusagen so ein ja so ein Mittelweg der
ihm da der ihm da bleibt wie gesagt ich
möchte einen Bluff kann man nicht genau
ausschließen aber wer immer wieder
betont wir haben das ja von der
russischen Propaganda hören wir das
ungefähr zwei dreimal am Tag dass sie
mit Atomwaffen drohen und die
Sprachrohre des Kremls verkünden dann
immer dass sie westliche Hauptstädte
einäschern würden und so weiter den
nimmt man irgendwann nicht mehr ganz
ernst das ist natürlich nicht so dass
man das alles als komplett nur abtun
sollte als Geschwätz aber es bleibt auch
die Frage inwiefern inwieweit die
russische Führung bereit ist zu gehen
mit dem Einsatz dieser Atomwaffen weil
sie eben nicht mehr
selbst wenn sie sozusagen diese
territorie nach diesen
scheinreferenteneingliedern dann den
Einsatz von Nuklearwaffen sozusagen
rechtfertigen würden mit einem Angriff
auf ihr neu hinzugewonnen ist
Territorium das natürlich
Lugansk oder dunetzke dass das was
anderes ist als St Petersburg oder
Moskau das heißt es natürlich auch die
Legitimation ist natürlich trotzdem
schwerer zu erklären weil eben es wird
eben nicht in St Petersburg oder Moskau
gekämpft insofern würde ich da
vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen
abwarten wir behalten die Live-Bilder
weiterhin im Blick also es sind die
scheinreferenten in den vier von
Russland besetzten Gebieten die sind
also durch jetzt will Putin diese vier
Regionen annektieren jetzt gibt es
hierzu auch eine offizielle Zeremonie
die soll es geben die Bilder gerade eben
haben wir gesehen aus dem Kreml Putin
soll auch eine Rede halten
und hier landen sie in Moskau die
Separatisten Führer sie feiern sich
und
offenbar das ist der ukrainische
Präsident
nein das sind die Separatisten Führer
genau wie sie in Moskau angekommen sind
sie feiern sich und offenbar jetzt auch
schon die anstehende Zeremonie mit Putin
die wir jetzt hier in diesen Minuten
live aus dem Kreml begleiten bei mir
nach wie vor auch im Studio unser
Bildreporter Björn Striezel wir haben
die Livebilder gerade aus eben aus dem
Kreml gesehen weißt du wer da alles
jetzt gerade auch in den ersten Reihen
sitzt wer ist jetzt da alles geladen wer
auf wen kommt es da an
also in den ersten Reihen geladen sind
natürlich die vertrauten Putins das
heißt die zum einen
diejenigen die im seinen Militärapparat
und in seinem geheimdienstapparat
sozusagen den den Ton angeben da würde
ich vermuten auch wenn ich die erste
Reihe nicht sehen kann die Gesichter
würde ich vermuten dass das da sozusagen
diese diese Führung ist der seiner
seiner Geheimdienste also das des FSB
des gäruhr und das SVR und die natürlich
dann auch noch flankiert werden von von
der militärischen Führung also sprich
dem Verein vom Verteidigungsminister und
dazu kommen dann mutmaßlich auch noch
Vertreter aus ja das was man sozusagen
dann die die zweite Reihe nennt
Oligarchen
Wirtschaftsbosse die die dem Kreml Chef
da besonders am Herzen liegen und dir
sozusagen auch
das hat ja noch einen weiteren Effekt
diese Zeremonie die ja sozusagen wir es
schon gemacht hat als er vor der
Invasion noch mal seine engsten
Vertrauten versammelt hatte in einer
Ansprache und sie jeweils Gründe hat
Vorbringen lassen für diese Invasion die
ja deswegen auch in einer solchen
Zeremonie präsentieren möchte weil sie
dann natürlich mit Täter sind weil er
sozusagen sich nicht nur ihre
Unterstützung nicht ihrer Unterstützung
vergewissern will sondern weil das
natürlich auch öffentlich ausgestrahlt
wird und dadurch auch sozusagen dann
jeder der dort erscheint der das dort
durch seinen durch seinen Teilnahme an
dieser Zeremonie in diesem ganzen diesen
ganzen ja dieser ganzen
Show sozusagen Legitimation verleiht der
ist dann der steht auch mit seinem
Gesicht mit seinem Namen mit seiner
Funktion dann eben dafür und dass es
eben auch eines dieser dieser
Machtspielchen die wir von Putin immer
wieder gesehen haben die vier von
Russland
besetzten Gebiete in der Ukraine sie
sollen heute feierlich annektiert werden
im Kreml das sind die Livebilder und wir
haben die Möglichkeit jetzt auch unseren
bild-vize Paul ronsheimer dazu zu holen
er steht in der Ostukraine heute also
der große annexion's Feiertag im Kreml
Paul was erwartest du
ich erwarte dass worüber wir in den
vergangenen Tagen und Stunden diskutiert
haben nämlich das Vladimir Putin eine
klare Drohung an die Ukraine und an die
Welt schickt das von nun an ab dem
Zeitpunkt wo aus seiner Sicht diese
Gebiete jetzt russisch sind die Angriffe
auf diese Region zu unterlassen sind
ansonsten werde das Konsequenzen haben
davon gehe ich aus ich gehe nicht davon
aus dass Vladimir Putin direkt
eskalieren wird sondern sehr
wahrscheinlich wird es eine Art
Ultimatum geben nur eines ist schon
jetzt klar wenn man hier mit
ukrainischen offiziellen spricht wenn
man mit Menschen im Umfeld von würde mir
selenski dem ukrainischen Präsidenten
spricht dann höre ich nur eines das
alles bewegt uns gar nicht es ist uns
egal was Wladimir Putin dort sagt wir
werden weiter kämpfen wir wollen unser
Land zurück haben und wenn man das dann
analysiert und sich anschaut wie auf der
einen Seite eben Wladimir Putin steht
und sagt hier bis hier und nicht
erweitern auf der anderen Seite die
Ukraine sagen wir werden weiter Land
zurückerobern und eines muss man sagen
das passiert ja momentan weiterhin
insbesondere in den Regionen im Osten in
limanen zum Beispiel da sind die Russen
so gut wie eingekesselt dann muss man
eines klar festhalten diese beiden Dinge
passen natürlich nicht zueinander es
wird eine Eskalation deshalb erwartet
hier in den nächsten Tagen Paul und in
diesen Sekunden betritt Wladimir Putin
den Kreml wir hören mal rein
bitteschön
verehrte Bürger und Bürger
Volksrepubliken
des Staats Duma sind das in Russland wo
ganz genau
wurden ausgezählt die Ergebnisse bekannt
haben ihre Wahl getroffen ihre
eindeutiger
verfassliche unterstützen gehört die
Aufnahme der 4
Generation weil das ist gut in Wilhelm
von Millionen von Menschen
haben natürlich das Recht das
unabdingbare Recht welches auch in dem
ersten Artikel der Vereinigten Nationen
verankert ist wo es um die
Gleichberechtigung und Selbstbestimmung
der Völker geht das ist ein
unabdingbares recht möchte ich noch mal
unterstreichen
basierend auf eine historischen Einheit
und um dies unseren Vorfahren ging die
auch schon immer
altertümlichen Russland Russland
verteidigte darum gings unseren Foren
Rumänien auf kämpften auf diesem
Gebieten neue Städte wurden hier
gegründet durch Katharina die Große und
verdammten unsere Väter und Großväter
kämpften hier bis zu ihrem hatten Tode
im Zweiten Weltkrieg auch
den können wir uns erinnern an die
vielen die nicht einverstanden waren mit
dem Staatsstreich in der Ukraine wir
gedenken all denen die umgekommen sind
die gestorben sind für die für das Recht
nach der eigenen Tradition
Kulturtradition zu leben eigene
Muttersprache zu sprechen da sind die
Opfer der hat ihn von Odessa
Opfer der Terroranschläge des
kiwa-regimes das sind die Freiwilligen
und die zivilverteidiger Frauen
ältere Menschen Kinder Russen Ukraine
Menschen unterschiedlicher
volkszügigkeiten und Ethnizitäten das
sind die Anführer der denn jetzt die
Republik her sakaracin
und andere Helden der dann jetzt gar
Republik
das ist ja Georg
Republik das ist ja ganz und ja alle
unsere Soldaten die
gestorben sind für die wir jetzt die
Republiken das sind unsere Helden und
die Helden des großen Russlands ich
bitte Sie
denen mit einer Schweigeminute zu
gedenken
vielen Dank
der Wahl von Millionen von Einwohner der
Volksrepublik in der Gebiete SAP
arrangiert
unser gemeinsames Schicksal und unsere
1000-jährige Geschichte diese geistige
Verbindung wurde von Generation zu
Generation übertragen trotz alle Härten
haben sie die Liebe zu Russland auf
Recht erhalten können und niemand kann
diese Liebe in uns vernichten deshalb
auch die ältere Generation und die
jungen Generationen die schon nach dem
Zerfall der Sowjetunion geboren wurde
stimmten für unsere gemeinsame Zukunft
im Jahr 1991 im Belege bald ohne die
Bevölkerung zu fragen haben die
damaligen Partei Spitzen die
Entscheidung getroffen unser Land
aufzuteilen auf einen Schlag wurde unser
Volk geteilt wirklich ähm
Leben Fleischer zerschnitten so wie es
eins schon nach der Oktober Revolution
gewesen war wo kürzlich die Grenzen
gezogen wurden so haben auch die letzten
Anführer der Sowjetunion trotz des
Referendums von 1991 haben Sie unser
großes Land zerstückelt und die haben
die Menschen die Bürger vor keiner Wahl
gestellt das war einfach eine vollendete
Tatsache sie wussten nicht sie konnten
sich nicht voll vorstellen zu welchen
Konsequenzen das führen würde aber das
ist nicht mehr wichtig es gibt keine
Sowjetunion die Vergangenheit kann man
nicht wiederbeleben und in das heutige
Russland braucht das nicht mehr das wird
von uns nicht angestrebt aber es gibt
nichts stärker als die Entschlossenheit
von Millionen von Menschen die nach
ihrer kulturkradition und Glauben
Sprache
die sich als Teil von Russland sehen
deren Vorfahren Jahrhunderte lang in
einem
Staat gelebt haben es gibt nicht stärker
als die Entschlossenheit diese Menschen
zurückzukehren zu ihrer historischen
Heimat in ihrer historische Heimat seit
acht Jahren gab es Völkermarkt
Völkermord in dorsbach
und interessant hat man versucht Hass in
diesen Menschen zu Tischen gegen
Russland
bedroht Frauen Kinder Lehrer
Schulpersonal
mit Repressionen die Menschen die ihren
freien Willen zum Ausdruck bringen
wollten aber das hat diese Menschen
nicht gebrochen sie haben ihr Wort
gesprochen ich möchte das die Geber
Macht haben und deren echten Herren im
Westen mich hören und als alle sich das
merken die Menschen die in Person
unserer Branche in Lorenz leben sie
werden zu unseren russischen
Staatsbürgern
für immer
wir hoffen dazu auf sofort
einzustellen das Feuer einzustellen alle
die griechischen Aktivitäten
einzustellen die schon im Jahr 2014
begonnen wurden und
an die Verhandlungstisch zurückzukehren
das haben wir mehrfach wiederholt aber
die Wahl der Menschen aus done
die Wahl ihre Wahl haben diese Menschen
getroffen
und Russland wird diese Wahl in dieser
Entscheidung nicht verraten
diese Entscheidung diese freien
Scheidung der Menschen respektieren
kann ein Weg zu einem Frieden Aussehen
Russland wird sein Gebiet mit allen
Mitteln diese Verfügung stehen
verteidigen wir werden alles Erdenkliche
tun um die Unabhängigkeit unserer
Menschen zu verteidigen das ist die
freiheitliche Mission unseres Volkes wir
werden die Häuser die Schulen Theater
und Museen Krankenhäuser wieder aufbauen
wir werden Industriebetriebe und die
Infrastruktur entwickeln wir werden die
sozialversorgung die rentenversorgung
wiederherstellen wir werden die Menschen
ausgeben wir haben natürlich deren
sicherheitsstärke wir werden so tun dass
die Bewohner dieser Gebiete die
Unterstützung von ganz Russland spüren
alle russischen Gebiete und Oblast
unserer großen Heimat
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich
Kollegen ich möchte heute unsere
Soldaten infiziere ansprechen die die
spezialoperation
durchführen an die Kämpfer von Don Bass
diejenigen ansprechen die heute im
Rahmen der Teil Mobilisierung sich mobil
machen oder freiwillig und sich unserer
Truppe
anschließend ich möchte deren Eltern und
Verwandte ansprechen ich möchte zeigen
mit welchem Feind wir zu tun haben wer
uns gegenübersteht wer aus dieser
Tragödie profitiert
unsere Landsleute in der Ukraine
ein Teil unseres Volkes in der Ukraine
hat mit eigenen Augen gesehen was der
Westen der ganzen Menschheit
bereitet hier war sind die Masken
gefallen und das Wesen
uns hat sich einblößt nach dem Zerfall
der Sowjetunion
hat der besten entschieden dass alle
Menschen der Welt sich mit dem Diktat
des ersten abfinden sollen sie dachten
das in den 90er Jahren Russland nicht
wieder auferstehen kann das Russland
nach dem Zerfall der Sowjetunion nie
wieder aufstehen kann
und das ist das Ende ist und das wäre
bei einer passiert wir hatten früher und
Kälte in den 90er Jahren aber nicht dass
du trotz ist Russland wieder stark und
hat wieder seinen Platz in der Welt
gefunden der am besten hat nach weiteren
Chancen gesucht ein Schlag Russland zu
verpassen damit Russland zerfällt in
vielen Staaten zur stückelt wird das ist
schon der jahrhundert als
Traum des Westens der besten befinden
sich keine Ruhe wenn es so ein riesiges
Land
mit der Bevölkerung die niemals sich
einem äußeren Druck beugen wird der
Westen tut alles Mögliche dafür um
dieses neokoloniale System auf
Restaurant halten um weiter an Regionen
der Welt zu plünder durch die Macht des
dollarsula dadurch haben sie ja die
weltweite Quelle diese Rente der
Hegemonie des Westens wird eingestrichen
das ist das eigentliche Ziel absolut
eigennütziges Ziel des Westens deswegen
mag der besten keine Souveränität
deswegen kommt die Aggression gegen
unabhängige Staaten gegen den
eigenständige Kulturen sie versuche die
Integration nicht kontrolliert zu
Integrationsprozess internationale
Prozesse zu unterminieren neue Währungen
zu unternehmen
Entwicklung zu zerstören wichtig ist für
den Westen dass alle Länder die eigene
Souveränität aufgeben ansonsten der
Vereinigten Staaten der Spitzen die
Spitzen bestimmter Länder tun das
freiwillig
sie machen ihre Staaten freiwillig zu
was zahlenstaaten des Westens die
anderen werden eingeschüchtert und wenn
sie das nicht machen werden
hinterlassen Millionen von Menschen
schiebt erzählen zerstört
an Glauben von sozialen Not Kolonien und
halbkolonien werden hinterlassen aber
den besten ist es ganz egal hauptsache
man zu den Nutzen darauf den eigenen
Nutzen diese Habgier
das Westens das Ziel die eigene
uneingeschränkte Macht über die Welt
aufrecht zu halten das sind die echten
Ursachen des Krieges den der besten
gegen Russland produzierte Russland auch
als eine Kolonie gesehen die möchten
keine gleichberechtigte Partnerschaft
sie möchten unser Land
dass wir seelenloses Sklaven werden
gegen unsere Kultur vor gegen unsere
Philosophen
dieser stellt Gefahr
für die Zielerreichung unsere
prospektivität unserer positiver
Entwicklung des Russlands das braucht
der besten nicht aber das braucht
brauchen wir das glaubst du dann das
Kraft ist dann selbst
erinnern dass der Anspruch auf die
Weltherrschaft schon mehrfach
zerschlagen wurde durch die
Widerstandskraft zwischen Volkes auch
heute werden wir unsere Werte und unsere
Heimat verteidigen können der Westen
denkt er kommt unbestraft davon
und bisher war das ja immer so viele
strategisch Gebirge die Abkommen im
strategischen Sicherheitsbereich werden
in den Papierkorb geschmissen die
Übereinkommen auf dem Niveau werden für
nicht Existenz erklärt die
Versprechungen und die NATO nicht nach
dem Osten zu erweitern nachdem unsere
staatsspielzeug und sich darauf einlässt
und puppten sich als Lügen
die Verträge wurden vom Besten zerrissen
und man hört immer wieder dass der
Westen die Weltordnung basierend auf
Regeln verteidigt
woher kommen diese Regeln wer hat denn
diese Regeln gesehen oder gelesen das
ist doch Schwachsinn welche Regeln denn
doppeltem Moral dreifache Standards wenn
möchten Sie für dumm halten Russland ist
ein Land und gleich Zivilisation
ist 1.000 Jahre alt und Russland wird
nicht nach solchen Schein Regeln des
Westens existieren wollen
[Applaus]
gerade der sogenannte Westen hat das
Prinzip der
Unantastbarkeit der Grenzen zerstört und
jetzt entscheidet der Westen selbst wer
hat das Recht auf Selbstbestimmung und
wer nicht wer ist sozusagen nicht würdig
warum weshalb der hat das Recht den
Besten
gegeben deswegen
die Entwicklungen in der Creme beim
SKK negativ bewertet wir hatten dieses
Recht den Besten gegeben der Westen darf
nicht die Demokratie selbst definieren
denn der besten negiert die Prinzipien
der Unantastbarkeit der Grenzen der ist
Souveränität der besten like zu
disputismus und apathiet der besten
teilt die Welt in zivilisierte Länder
die eigenen vasalen die nicht
zivilisierten Länder die nicht ihre
basalen sind Länder sind also man
erklärt manche Staaten zu
Schurkenstaaten und die anderen zu nicht
würdig
ganze Staaten ganze Völker werden durch
den Westen gebranntmark und das ist ja
auch nichts Neues die westlichen Eliten
sind so wie sie ist schon immer waren da
sind Kolonisatoren sie unterteilen die
Völker der Welt in die richtigen und
richtigen
wir werden so ein politischen
Nationalismus und Rassismus niemals
akzeptieren die russophobie die momentan
in der ganzen Welt verbreitet wird
anders als Rassismus die Überzeugung des
Westen dass die eigene Zivilisation die
neoliberale Kultur ein Vorbild für die
ganze Welt ist
deshalb das ist seltsam
die eigenen historischen Verbrechen des
Westens und die Tirol die der besten
manchmal zum Ausdruck bringt auch da
wird geschult die anderen in die Schuhe
geschoben die Völker die damit nichts zu
tun haben sollen auch Rollen zum
Beispiel die ehemaligen kolonial-länder
die Kolonialpolitik des Westens alle
Mittelalter danach kam der Sklavenhandel
der weltweite handelt dann der das
Indianern in Amerika da sind die Kriege
von England und Frankreich gegen China
weshalb dann China die eigentlich helfen
aufmachen und er musste für Opium Handel
die ganzen
wurden mit Drogen behandelt ganze
Zeiten wurden vernichtet um damit der
Westen anderen Ressourcen dran kommt man
jagte die Menschen die Tiere damit das
Ziel erreicht ist das zerstört gegen
Freiheit und
Feuchtigkeit aber wir als Russland sind
stolz dass im 20 Jahrhundert gerade
unser Land die
antikolonialbewegung anführte
gegen Armut und Krankheiten gegen
Unterentwicklung einer der wichtigsten
Gründe der Russe Phobie dieses
Ärgers der westlichen Elite besteht
darin oder kommen daher das Russland ist
nicht zuließ dass es gibt plündert wird
das Russland immer wieder darauf
hingewirkt hat dass man
gleichberechtigten handelt betreibt
russland hat einen zentralisierten Staat
in der Geschichte schaffen können und
diese Stadt wurde immer stärker basiert
auf bestimmten moralischen Werten von
der orthodoxen griechischen Glauben dem
Dualismus und dem Islam
basierend auf der
weltoffenen russischen Kultur und
Sprache es gab viele ausländische
Interventionen und Eingriffe in Russland
im 17 Jahrhundert nach 1917 aber das
misslang doch Ende des 20 Jahrhunderts
als unser Staat zerstört wurde kam der
besten endlich mal an unsere Ressourcen
man nannte uns Freund und Partner aber
in der Tat weiß die Haltung gegenüber
Russland
wie die Haltung gegen eine klassischen
Kolonie man hat so viele Natur
Ressourcen aus Russland gepumpt in den
90er Jahren und wie man das nicht
vorstellen kann das habe ich nicht
vergessen nun haben die Republiken bin
jetzt und du Hans und die Gebiete
separage und Person sich dafür aus
gesprochen die historische Einheit
unseres Landes wiederhergestellt wird
vielen Dank
die westlichen Länder haben wir hunderte
lang alle gesagt sie bringen anderen
Völkern Freiheit und Demokratie
ganz im Gegenteil statt Demokratie eine
Ausbeutung statt Freiheit eine
Versklavung und Gewalt
die ganze unipolare Weltordnung ist
antidemokratisch ist unfrei dem Wesen
her das ist Heuchlerei bis zum geht
nicht mehr
und wir sprechen von dem Land welches
schon zweimal Atomwaffen ein Gesetz hat
das sind doch die präsidenzfälle hier
Simon nakosak geworden
militärische Notwendigkeit wurden
mehrere Städte im Zweiten Weltkrieg den
Boden eben gemacht nicht nur in Japan
sondern auch in Deutschland Dresden
Hamburg ohne die militärischen
Notwendigkeit wie schon gesagt habe und
diese Städte wirklich zerstört der ist
das einzige Ziel davon war die Menschen
einzuschüchtern da und auch die Menschen
in der Sowjetunion die USA haben
schreckliche Spuren in Gedächtnis der
Völker von Korea und Vietnam
hinterlassen sie haben dort chemische
Waffen eingesetzt sie haben dort Napalm
eingesetzt
die südkoreanische Republik Japan
Deutschland die sind doch nach wie vor
besetzt und ganz zynisch sprechen die
USA von Partnern aber was für eine
Partnerschaft das ist jeder weiß doch
dass selbst die
Stadt Oberhäupter abgehört werden
nicht nur in ihrem dienstlichen sondern
auch in ihrem privaten Bereich das ist
doch Schande Scham und Schande an
diejenigen die das tun und diejenigen
die das Stillschweigen schlucken das
einfach schlucken
und die
Rufe die eigen zahlen die gegenüber zu
Solidarität das auch fürchterei die
Entwicklung von chemischen biologischen
Waffen in der Ukraine in den biolaboren
Forschung genannt die Plünderung
der Ukraine unter anderem und andere
Länder führte dazu dass es tausenden
hunderttausende Flüchtlinge gibt die
nach Europa und anders Vorrennen
momentan wird Getreide aus der Ukraine
ausgeführt unter dem Vorwand die ärmsten
Länder zu unterstützen aber hin fließt
das Getreide das Getreide gehen doch
überwiegend nach Europa nur fünf Prozent
von dem ukrainischen Getreide ging
wirklich in die ärmsten Länder
das ist doch wieder betrug in direkter
betrug wie immer
die amerikanischen Eliten
nutzen praktisch die Tragödie dieser
Menschen aus um die eigenen
Konkurrenten zu vernichten um den
entsprechenden Staaten zu schwächen das
betrifft Europa das betrifft die
nationale Identität von Frankreich
Italien Deutschland und andere Länder
mit der eigenen langjährigen Geschichte
und sie fahren noch mehr Sanktionen
gegen Russland die meisten europäischen
Politiker die lenken ein
dieser Druck der USA auf Europa sich
komplett auf die russischen Ressourcen
zu verzichten dass dieser Druck eine
komplette der Industrialisierung Europas
bedeutet die europäischen riesen
verstehen da sie verstehen dass die
Amerikaner den europäischen Markt
komplett einnehmen möchten aber die
bevorzugen ist erst
fremde Interessen zu bedienen das ist
keine Latein
das ist die Bedienung der fremden
Interessen und Verrat aber die
Sanktionen reichen nicht jetzt kommst du
Terroranschlägen und Sabotage
Explosionen an nordstream Pipelines in
der Ostsee ist ein Beispiel also die USA
sind dazu übergegangen die einheitliche
europäische Energieinfrastruktur zu
zerstören wem nützt das muss man die
Frage stellen wem das nützt der hat dann
auch getan das ist ganz einfach die
machte USA basiert auf und wir holen den
Gewalt manchmal versteckte Gewalt aber
die Macht der stärkeren das ist doch
deren Hauptregel der Weltordnung dadurch
die unzähligen amerikanischen
Militärstützpunkte in der ganzen Welt
die Erweiterung die versuchen neue
militärische Allianzen wie August
zusammen zu schmieden zusammen zu
schustern
man versucht neu Einigung zwischen
Washington SEO und Tokio zu erreichen
alle Staaten die strategische
Souveränität anstreben und die eine
Herausforderung für die Hegemonie des
bestens darstellen die werden
automatisch zu feinen erklärt
darauf basieren die Militär Doktrinen
der USA und der NATO basierend auf die
Idee der total Dominierung die
westlichen elinen verkaufen das aber
voll heuchlerisch mit einem Anspruch auf
eine friedliche Existenz
und diese diese Lügen und verdeckte
Lügen die spazieren von einem Land zu
dem nächsten aber das Ziel ist doch
einfach geht wieder souveräne
Entwicklungszentren der Welt zu
intervenieren Russland einzudämmen Iran
einzudämmen ich denke dass auch andere
Länder bald dran sind wenn der von
Lateinamerika Länder Afrikas und Asiens
aber auch die heutigen sogenannten
Partner der USA wenn die USA das einmal
irgendwann nicht mögen werden sie
Sanktionen einführen gegen westliche
Firmen Banken und dann nach Länder das
ist doch die gängige Praxis die
ausgebaut wird
alle sind die Zielscheibe die USA und da
unsere unmittelbaren Nachbarn in der
Gemeinschaft und entgegen starten aber
das ist doch dieses Wunschdenken der USA
als sie mit dem man sanktionsblitz Krieg
gegen Russland begann dachten sie die
ganze Welt wird sich
gehörig auf rein aber scheinbar möchten
nicht alle Länder so eine rosige
Perspektive bis auf die Masochisten
Staaten und andere
Anhänger von nicht traditionellen
internationalen Beziehungen andere
Staaten wählen doch aber eine
vernünftige Zusammenarbeit mit Russland
und diese Ungehorsam wurde von den USA
vom Besten nicht erwartet Sie Verfahren
doch schablonenhaft
Einschüchterung
betrug
Bestechung sie denken das kann auch so
weitergehen als würde man in der
Vergangenheit verharren das ist doch
dieser
Selbstsicherheit beim multipliziert mit
der besonderen selbst Wahrnehmung
und die Wahrheit wurde
durch Lügen
die aggressive propagando
informationsblockade die blanken Lügen
erklärt also vier ukrainische Gebiete zu
russischem Staatsgebiet die Aufnahme
soll heute noch vertraglich besiegelt
werden bei mir im Studio nach wie vor
unser Bild Reporter Björn strietze was
waren für dich die bedeutendsten Punkte
in dieser Rede
er spricht ja noch also bis jetzt was
ich am interessantesten fand schon der
war schon der Einstieg also es hat
natürlich diese erwartete diese
erwartete defensive Haltung dass er sich
Russland immer wieder als als Opfer
geriert und zwar als Opfer des Westens
seit Jahrhunderten spricht dann immer
wieder von Kolonialismus erwähnt
natürlich nie das wie Russland denn
entstanden ist also so ein Riesenreiches
ja auch nicht einfach das ist ja nicht
natürlich entstanden sondern natürlich
auch als als Folge russischer
Expansionsbestrebungen und dann ist eben
der was mich so wenig überrascht hat in
der Deutlichkeit der Unterschied den er
macht zur Sowjetunion unbeabsichtigt
wahrscheinlich dass er nämlich
einerseits sozusagen an die
sozusagen an die an die Größe der
Sowjetunion erinnert und an den an den
ja auch an die militärische Macht als
man sich auf Augenhöhe gesehen hat mit
den USA und dann kommt er aber zu
sprechen darauf dass sozusagen es eine
Zerstückelung gegeben habe und dass man
nun und dann kommt er eben später heraus
warum unsere Staatsgebiete wieder oder
sozusagen einverleibt werden müssen und
begründet das mit mit Sprach- und
Tradition und das ist etwas was
sozusagen eine Abkehr ist von dem was er
eigentlich davor gemacht hat zu
Sowjetunion den Sowjetunion hat ja bei
allem unerfüllten Anspruch bei allem
Propaganda sich zumindest nach außen hin
immer verstanden als Vaterland der
Werktätigen er war das entscheidende
Element eben nicht Sprache Tradition
Kultur und dergleichen sondern dass man
ein anderer politischer Anspruch und den
gibt er im Prinzip auf sondern er
definiert das als etwas also völkisch
esoterisches fast mit begründeter
irgendeine gemeinsame Tradition und
Sprache und Kultur und erklärt daraus
leitet daraus so ein Anspruch ab und
dann kommt eben diese ganze Litanei noch
mal mit dem Westen der sozusagen ja
Russland halt immer nur ausgebeutet
hätte und so weiter und der jetzt auch
schuld sei sozusagen an dem an dem
russischen Einmarsch in der Ukraine und
das ist halt so
eine so offensichtliche täteropfer
Umkehr in dem Fall wenn es auf die
Ukraine bezieht das ist Wladimir Putin
und seine russischen Streitkräfte die in
der Ukraine eingefallen sind und nicht
umgekehrt dazu immer noch mal wieder
eingestreut so kleinere lügen wenn er
von Chemie und biologischen
waffenlaboren spricht in der Ukraine die
der besten angeblich vorbereitet müssen
uns mal in Erinnerung rufen es ist
Russland was Chemiewaffen eingesetzt hat
in bei Anschlägen in Europa und es ist
Russland was was ich großer
chemiewaffenangriffe durch sein
Verbündeten Syrien Diktator Assad in
Syrien zugelassen und befördert hat
insofern das sind alles solche
klassische täteropfer umkehrt Jesu
defensiv daherkommt und die eigentlich
nur das eigene los schlagen dann
legitimieren will also eine große Reise
des kriegstreibenden Präsidenten
Russlands Wladimir Putin lass uns noch
unseren Bild viel zu Paul ronsheimer
live aus rakif dazu holen Paul Putin hat
gesprochen wie ist diese Rede von ihm
einzuordnen
es war aus unserer Sicht eine erwartbar
wäre Rede es gipfelte darin fand ich als
er den USA vorgeworfen hat dass sie Nazi
Deutschland bombardiert haben also so
absurd ist es schon in Putins Kopf
mittlerweile unabhängig von diesen ja
üblichen Vorwürfen gegen den Westen fand
ich eine Sache ganz entscheidend der hat
gesagt
diese Region sind jetzt Russisch und Sie
werden immer russisch bleiben das ist
eine klare Drohung Richtung Westen aber
auch Richtung Ukraine die ja in diesen
Regionen weiter kämpfen gerade zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt findet eine
Einkesselung bei Liman statt ist es
nicht klar welche militärische
Konsequenz Wladimir Putin daraus sieht
also er hat nicht z.B erneut mit einer
oder stand jetzt mit einer nuklevar
Waffe gedroht der redet ja weiterhin zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt allerdings ist es so
dass das natürlich eine klare Ansage ist
und er hat das verbunden damit dass er
gesagt hat er sei jetzt auch bereits zu
verhandeln also seine Aussage ist das
sind unsere Region und jetzt lass uns
hinsetzen und verhandeln er weiß
natürlich dass das unrealistisch ist und
die Ukraine weiterkämpfen wird aber er
versucht sicherlich auch damit so ein
bisschen den Westen zu spalten indem er
sagt ich bin ja bereit zu verhandeln
Paul Björn lasst uns noch unseren
BILD-Reporter Dimitri seubel dazu holen
er steht an der georgisch-russischen
Grenze hier versuchen die Russen nämlich
gerade zu fliehen vor der Einberufung
Wladimir Putins Dimitri wie reagiert man
vor Ort bei dir jetzt auf diese Rede von
Putin hat man davon mitbekommen welche
Informationen sind schon durchgedrungen
die Menschen hier vor Ort haben
natürlich schon seit Stunden darauf
gewartet ich habe gerade mit mich mit
mit Russland unterhalten die ganze
passiert dann die dann gebannt oder
gespannt auf diese Rede gewartet haben
ihre größte Sorge war dass da eine
allgemeine mobil machen
ausgerufen wird dass sein Kriegszustand
in Russland ausgerufen wird und das im
Prinzip das ist auch der Grund wieso ist
sie eben mit den Füßen also abgestimmt
haben und eben ihr Land verlassen haben
dass sie so ruckartig ihre Sachen
geparkt haben und eben über die Grenze
weg sind bzw erst nach Georgien
geflüchtet sind Vorhaben natürlich auch
dann weiter auch nach Deutschland weiter
zu reisen
Paul in rakev die annektierten Gebiete
in der Ukraine die sind zerstört er hat
das angesprochen wie wird es da
weitergehen
es wird dort mit dem Krieg weitergehen
der schon jetzt krieg ist wir haben
heute diese grausamen
Angriffe in saporicia gesehen wo 23
Zivilisten getötet wurden ich gehe davon
aus dass dieser Krieg sich noch weiter
intensivieren wird in den nächsten
Stunden möglicherweise in den nächsten
Tagen und ich gehe davon aus dass dort
ein bisschen lensky der ukrainische
Präsident auch in den nächsten Stunden
auf diese Rede reagieren wird dann stand
jetzt tagt immer noch der Sicherheitsrat
in der Ukraine und man diskutiert dort
wie man auf diese Annektion und auf
diese Aussagen von Putin reagieren wird
was muss jetzt die Antwort des Westens
aus deiner Sicht sein Paul
der Westen darf sich auf keinen Fall
einschüchtern lassen das ist das was
Putin möchte putin will jetzt dass wir
uns auseinander dividieren das ist
Debatten möglicherweise um
Waffenlieferung gibt dass es ein Druck
gibt auf die ukrainische Führung sich in
irgendeiner Art zu Verhandlungen zu
bewegen das kann und Sorge machen denn
wir haben nach 2014 ja bereits gesehen
dass der Westen auf einer Annektion
damals der Krim eben mit schwächeren
Sanktionen oder schwachen Sanktionen
reagiert hat und das sonst hat geschehen
lassen die Sorge habe ich nicht dass es
im gleichen Falle passiert weil die
Situation heute eine andere ist aber
dennoch das natürlich Putins Taktik ist
jetzt ja Europa dort zu ins Weinen
Deutschland zu spalten und in den
nächsten Monaten durch eine
vermöbungstaktik dafür zu sorgen dass
der Westen dann druck macht auf die
Ukraine zu verhandeln was ich höre ist
das aus ukrainischer Sicht nicht möglich
man kriegt nicht davon aus dass man in
irgendeiner Form jetzt noch verhandeln
kann das hat sel auch klar gesagt nach
der Annektion schließt der Verhandlung
mit Russland aus Björn Striezel auch
nach wie vor bei uns im Studio an
welcher Stelle hatte ich Putin
vielleicht auch überrascht in seiner
Rede gab es da einen Moment
also eine wirklich Überraschung habe ich
da eigentlich nicht
konnte ich nicht ausmachen sondern es
tatsächlich eher das was man was man
erwarten konnte ich habe es ja vorher
auch gesagt dass man da mit einer
relativ defensiven Rede rechnen kann und
genauso ist es dann auch tatsächlich
eingetreten es war dieses übliche wir
stehen in einem Abwehrkampf gegen gegen
den Westen der uns seit Jahrhunderten
bedrängt der uns unsere Ressourcen
klauen möchte und der ständig angeblich
Verträge breche das ist natürlich auch
nicht der Fall gewesen sondern es war
tatsächlich Russland was zum Beispiel in
ihren f-vertrag mit der Stationierung
seiner ist kann da in Kaliningrad dann
zum Einsturz gebracht hat
das war die groß angekündigte Rede
Vladimir Putins live aus dem Kreml Putin
erklärt also vier ukrainische Gebiete zu
russischem Staatsgebiet die Aufnahme
soll heute noch vertraglich besiegelt
werden dazu haben wir gesprochen mit mir
einen Striezel hier bei mir im Studio
mit bild-zeit Paul ronsheimer live
austrages und Dimitri soll an der
russisch georgischen Grenze
[Musik]